now to our exclusive interview with
President Trump which wrapped up just
moments ago chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge is live
at the White House tonight good evening
Catherine well thank you Mike and good
evening we've just finished 20 minutes
to sit down with a president Trump we've
covered a wide variety of topics
including the Attorney General William
bar who refused to go to the House
Judiciary Committee on the basis that he
would take questions from committee
staff lawyers he also addressed the
issue of whether he would allow the
former White House Counsel dawn McGann
to testify to Congress here's part of
the interview well I've had him
testifying already for 30 hours so if
the answer is really so I don't think I
can let him and then tell everybody else
you can't because especially him because
he was a counsel so they've testified
for many hours all of them you're
concerned it's really a black diamond so
no one can and the others can't so it's
a tie I would say it's done we've
overdue this nobody has ever done what
I've done I've given total transparency
it's never happened before like this so
Congress should be a conversation
shouldn't be looking anymore this is all
it's done even my finances it must have
been looked at 435 million dollars I
assume they looked at my taxes I assume
that Muller looked at my financial
statements 435 million dollars and
having 20 people plus 49 FBI agents and
all of the staff and all of the money
that was spent they assumed they looked
at my taxes which are fine and I assume
except they are under audit by the way I
will tell you that officially because
Attorney General is coming at you pretty
hard
well she campaigned on the fact that oh
I'm gonna get Trump I'm gonna get Trump
so right there she's precluded from
doing anything I mean can you imagine
somebody campaigning doesn't know
anything about me and she's campaigning
on that fact so I assumed that for the
35 million dollars they've gone through
everything my taxes my financial
statements which are phenomenal they've
gone through everything and I'm so clean
think of it after two and a half years
and all of that money spent nothing very
few people could have sustained that
he also wanted at length about Attorney
General William Bar saying it was his
call I decide not to go and testify
today before the House Judiciary
Committee and he made the point that he
felt that the Attorney General was being
treated differently or unfairly if you
will we also asked him about Venezuela
and specifically if there was a physical
threat to one Guido or if he was
detained how the US would respond to his
part of that section he's actually a
brave person and because I know what
he's going through I'm speaking to our
people all the time he's a brave guy and
what's happening in Venezuela said when
you look at 20 years ago is one of the
wealthiest countries in the world if you
think about it and now they don't have
food and they don't have water and
people are dying from hunger it's a very
very serious situation what are your red
lines in Venezuela I don't want to say
but we have lots of options and some of
them are very tough options is there a
tipping point for military intervention
there's always a tipping point but
certainly I'd rather not do that I just
want to help the people the people are
dying
they have nothing these were people that
were living well 20 years ago
Catharine they have nothing they don't
have water and food and they're dying of
hunger right on the border it's terrible
and we also asked the president about
the 2020 race especially given another
Democrat has entered the field senator
Bennett and the president had some
surprising answers on how he thinks the
Democratic field is shaping up and who
he thinks he may face about 18 months
from now you're not gonna win seems to
have a lead I'd be very happy if it were
Biden happy watch Joe I think he does a
I think he did a bad job but be running
against so you think he's beatable
I just don't think he'd be a very good
candidate I mean we'll see what happens
I hope you know I wish him well I'd like
him to get it I'd be happy I'd be happy
with Bernie I personally think it's
those two between those two I think it's
between those two I don't see anybody
else but for me you never know now in my
case would you rather fight
and I think I was pretty much right I
know I was at the top from the beginning
I think he is now leading Bernie would
be second we'll see what happens
who would you rather face oh well I
don't want to say that to you but I
don't think it matters very much I think
we're gonna do well we have the
strongest economy that we've ever had
we're doing phenomenally we have the
best unemployment numbers
african-american Asians Hispanics best
numbers we've ever had women the best in
61 years unemployment numbers job
numbers wealth numbers we had the best
numbers we I think we have the best
economy we've ever had and we have more
people Catherine working right now than
ever in the history of our country so I
don't know why somebody beats that I
can't comment on some statements the
Vice President made while he was
campaigning in Iowa he said China is
quote not competition for us for the US
are you talking about which vice
president
I'm sorry former Vice President Biden
advisor he wouldn't have been a state
primary Mike Pence would not have made
that statement
everyone's competition I view everybody
as competition it's about China
well here's very naive about China China
right now we lose 500 billion after I
signed the dealer won't be anything like
that China just during the Obama years
in particular just took advantage of our
country so badly a very very big
competition China and I've stopped it
and I am stopping it you know during the
course of the last two and a half years
we've gone up 17 trillion dollars in
value China has gone down 17 trillion
dollars China as you know has taken a
very very big hit because of the tariffs
and everything else I've imposed we'll
see whether or not we have a deal we
have a very good chance to have a great
deal but for somebody to be so naive and
say that China is not a problem if iDEN
actually said that that's a very dumb
step that we also asked the president a
series of questions about sir the next
phase of this Russia investigation which
is the genesis of the FBI's
counterintelligence investigation in
2016
and he told us that he expects the
declassification of these Russia records
those are the surveillance warrant
applications he intimated weeks maybe a
couple of months but in effect that is
coming soon I also asked him to address
an editorial in the New York Times an
opinion piece by the former FBI director
where he called the president quote
amoral and he claimed that had rubbed
off on the Attorney General and Deputy
Attorney General I asked the president
if you take director Comey kind of out
of the mix or the equation if you will
over the last couple of years whether
the country would really be in the same
place and the president essentially said
that he felt that director Comey shared
a lot of the blame for where we are
today in the end the division if you
will Mike in the country fascinating
conversation congratulations caption
thanks very much you can see more of
Katherine's exclusive interview with
President Trump tonight at 11:00 p.m.
Eastern on Fox News at night with
shannon bream